New research claims that almost all dinosaurs
had feathers.
'You have a turd in your teeth' was a common
insult in 17th-century England.
Matt LeBlanc was down to his last $11 when
he got the part of Joey in Friends.
Two-thirds of all bankruptcies in the US are
caused by medical bills.
The busiest polling station in the Australian
elections is in London.
Whales can't taste anything but salt.
More than 80,000 bartenders in America have
university degrees.
There's a tree in South Africa so big that
a pub has been built inside its trunk.
Hermit crabs form gangs to steal shells from
other hermit crabs.
You could shatter a diamond with a hammer.
Diamonds may be one of nature's hardest materials
but they're not the toughest; there's a difference.
The toughest gemstone is actually nephrite
jade.
The world's largest chicken nugget is twice
the size of the world's largest chicken.
Half the world's population has a genetic
mutation that makes Brussels sprouts taste
extremely nasty.
A 'quarter pounder' weighs less than a fifth
of a pound when cooked.
People who try to stop thinking about chocolate
eat more of it than those who don't.
The first time Hitler and Mussolini met, Mussolini
described Hitler as a 'mad little clown'.
Due to a computer error in 1989, 41,000 Parisians
received letters charging them with murder,
extortion and prostitution instead of traffic
offences.